hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play among this
sleep now this is game that I've been
eagerly awaiting um you guys have been
telling me about it non-stop and I
finally managed to get hold of the
Kickstarter alpha so you guys can check
a link in the description below to take
you to the Kickstarter page but be aware
this game is not fully released yet you
can support it to get access to the
Alpha but for now if you can't do that
you can watch me play the game and see
for yourself when the eventual game gets
released later this year so let's give
it a try I'm all excited this is much
better of the baby blues time for bed
now so goodnight precious I will see you
son my mother sang to me when I was
young
well that's not a good sound huh how
doesn't know I don't know how that song
was supposed to be reassuring at all
but anyway or I'm not a baby I'm a
toddler I either way baby toddlers same
thing you know you know it's the same
deal
they're all young uns and somehow we got
a we got a wander through the house by
ourselves for some hey my teddy I don't
take my bear way bear are you getting up
okay yeah don't take my bear what are
you doing hey that's mine what the hell
why wha uh okay for some reason those
drapes look like Slenderman for some
reason whoa
hey I was sleeping there oh okay I am
fully in it for the for the toddler
phase and somehow my whole crib got
tipped over and I am just a wee little
baby I can open things like an amnesia
is the control scheme is oh yeah that's
very cool her I don't know how good
that'll do me
we're hanging maybe I could like climb
up these I don't know I can't exactly uh
no I cannot I cannot climb it well
anyway we were just wandering around I
don't have a flashlight or anything I
don't even know why I expected a toddler
just he's like Tommy from the Rugrats he
just whips into his diaper and whips out
a flashlight or whatever he needs right
down in there nope this guy is totally
unprepared okay froggy lay huh must be
French oh look it's a parakeet
Araki parrot I don't know I don't know
what that is I'm not an expert on aviary
creatures oh it's too high I can't reach
it it's too high okay so that's not
gonna work I can't reach that let's push
it to chair over maybe
cut out what is that
father father is that you okay oh there
we go I gotta push that over okay I
pushed it over I'm now trapped inside it
now I gotta somehow I would get up you
how much button
whoa what oh I was crawling really I
could see oh I had no idea I was
crawling okay well then let's hop up
here hold down space to hop up and
kajigger what right who's crying for
help
father father are you having a rough
time in the bathroom please Oh
hello
hello that Teletubby soap is this the
[ __ ] cubbies game there's a closet
here maybe I need to hide in this okay
run run look I'm a nutria Darla
look at me oh I'm so adorable oh look at
this look at Arcana I guess I'm in a
horror game where were the cries for
help coming from downstairs maybe oh it
is dark dark dark dark dark dark dark
dark dark dark I can barely see the oh
wait the stairs looking over there
they're just blocked by this child
Locker child lock I need to get a key to
be able to open that where do I get a
key let me search the laundry room again
because I feel like I might have skipped
over some important details
seriously what's going on downstairs
what what do you do what are you doing
we do it are you and mommy wrestling a
gun got turn it off oh I get it
I'm smart oh yeah so smart now open this
up and get the key whoa a teddy bear
but daddy oh that was my teddy crying
for help it was your mother
go to your mother was it go to your
mother it was your mother because one or
the other depends on whether I should go
to her or not Oh righto hey you got to
be more clear I know you've been
drowning in a washing machine there's no
dryer here what you cheapskate Bailey hi
no thank you I don't want any you could
go away this game is really cool I I
really like the idea I mean it's very
rarely done that you play a game from a
toddler's perspective I think I remember
way back when there was one game maybe
um they had a similar theme but I can't
remember well it is it's just I got this
feeling in the back of my head that
there might be another one out there but
as far as I know this is like the first
implemented horror version of this but
it's really cool I mean it's just such
an amazingly interesting concept I mean
as a toddler you're scared of everything
in the dark so they're like these may be
real threats or they may not be I mean
they seem real you're talking to your
bear I mean I wonder what the full game
is gonna be like because I imagine it
can't all take place in the house
because it's gonna be a long game like
at least like several hours if not more
so I think you have to go in the woods
for lightning don't bother me now
maybe you'll meet wish this Landy bad
hello what is this taco touka Karthik on
see there's some sort of boxes here not
television I don't want to sell they
don't even put on something appropriate
for me
what was that who dropped something I'm
going to crawl crawl like a baby I was
getting tired of walking anyway look at
me what is that on my oh is that the
pair the Bears on my back okay
hmm what why oh hey who left the fridge
open I better close this my bottle no
Baba where where I'm a baby where we is
there something in there oh that's
something important what is this
ah stick floor or coast
oh is this in swedenland or some
Norwegian country Scandinavian I mean
out Norwegian country coz there's only
one Norwegian country and that's Narwhal
is a great country of Narwhal okay let's
see if we can climb up I mean I'm
assuming that that's what I can do with
these since they're lovely and staircase
shaped come on no can't be
but this is a good hiding spot for when
the monsters want to murder my face I
still haven't seen a monster but the
game has definitely got the atmosphere
although all about it I mean I'm really
impressed by the like it feels I don't
know if it's more helpless but then
before because I'm technically I'm going
slower but it doesn't feel that way
because I am still you know I'm still um
I'm just a baby the perspective has
dropped but in a way I'm still going
slow so I feel even more helpless like
if I monster actually did show up I
don't know
I don't know what I do like seriously
what would I do I'm a baby never gonna
do I doubt someone
hi boy what's in there I don't want to
know oh i know eivol yeah
press G you'll get the teddy bear oh
hello oh oh I'm hugging my teddy bear
hello let's do this it'll make me feel a
little better we will do it what am i
doing
this house has really strange loud who's
in there
was that me breathing what was that some
diabolical monster in that room
breathing well let's find out why don't
we hello
teddy protect me don't be daddy can't
even open hello
seriously the layout of this house not
to make any sense at all what is going
on Canada Canada are we in Canada where
are we Canada Sweden can open these no
this is safe here what's in the safe a
decapitated head a bleeding heart it's
gonna be okay everybody just hold onto
your Teddy's okay boom what is this
where am i where am I Danah I need to
get to that I need to get hang on maybe
if I ooh
can I climb up this please is that a
keyboard that's the worst texture of a
keyboard I've ever seen in my life can I
not open these oh come on I need to be
able to jiggy that hammer through that
handle not the hammer okay maybe there's
a stool in here that I can grab yeah no
I can't grab these things well then how
am I supposed to be able to do anything
Anna
hello am i standing I'm standing right
okay it's gotta be a well a little
economy whoo gotta be a week boots boots
no boots do nothing the boots are do NER
think I can reach that like can I reach
that I don't know I don't think I can
huh I just don't think I can go in there
hang on I must be missing something I
messed him I must have passed by
something else that I can't think I
can't I can't for some reason I can't
seem to map this house out in my head
it's all very strange
I'm why are these doors blocked up why
what are you keeping out or in I'm the
demon I'm a demon baby oh it makes so
much sense now hello toys for some
reason Oh duh cuz I got the bear in my
hands I can't do anything cuz I got the
bear in my hands oh I'm so stupid
I'm so stupid markiplier of course you
can't do anything good to get a friggin
bear in your hands well apparently you
can't run unless you're crawling I guess
that makes sense cuz you got no
coordination let's see here your jerk
good ok now I should be able to climb up
this right yeah yeah look at me go I
knew it was on the right track I just uh
I just wasn't able to properly
coordinates come on come on come on come
on oh come on
ok I guess that's it what I can't whoa
whoa whoa whoa now you decided to do
some ok come on there we go there we go
finally yes alright sweet now do a sick
jump off of this you know this hard
let's not don't hurt the baby
what's in that lump what's in that lump
today project me what's in the law is
there someone in that lump mommy oh man
why is it baby crib so far from what's
in the lump I climb up here I can hunt
good I don't think I want to be in there
anyway
this door is properly illuminated solid
hey I can't even touch this door okay
let me get the chair hey probably I'm
probably supposed to go on the bed to
try to protect myself
what's the demon mommy demon mommy
you're not my mom you're not my mama
yeah
oh no oh mama I'm a bakery hello who's
there who's there no thank you I want
him going I would rather not I would
rather not what I'm doing it anyway
because I've got an audience to show
I've got not his show why do I have an
audience to show hmm all right stop
being such a baby and let's get brave
can I open this door no I cannot let's
leave it to wherever diabolical demon
seriously how big is this house oh it's
the kitchen again wait a minute you
thought I come through here did I come
through here that doesn't make any sense
where's my family ha ha ha ha what how
is that oh my god what the hell was that
supposed to be ha ha what the hell was
that it looked like it had a gigantic
knife ha ha ha
alright then this uh never come across
yeah hello
wow that is a creepy-looking teddy bear
look at sick or that's uh supposed to be
a cat I don't know
hey freaky-looking let's go teddy
let's go teddy there's some not-so-nice
things in this house we're gonna go home
like a book what is it there's something
in there I see it I see it right there
what is that
ha oh it's a like an invisible barrier
what white what is this
wah wah ha ha okay so my parents got
some invisible portal going on in their
house this is normal it's perfectly
normal
oh let's go in why not let's see what
does got what's the worst that could
happen
what's the words good good Abbot daddy
protect me protect me teddy what is that
what is this what is going on why is
that like that what is it that a water
jug what is this I don't know but away
teddy what is this what did I just get
hood what what crawl crawl
crawl on my belly throw it cuz I'm so
strong get out here
got your stones hurt here we go
what is what is what is this some sort
of demon demon organ room I don't know
let's go in I guess why not let's let's
climb right in ah we ha ha hey hold your
hands up in the air we water ha ha so
there was a pipe leading into baby hell
what let me make it a little bit this
baby has issues this baby's a little
dimension I am pretty sure that nothing
else is actually weird in this game huh
and this baby is just rather strange
suck you know in thumb games there are
little demon girls this one's a little
demon baby that's gotta be it
hello is anybody home is anybody oh wait
I couldn't touch it what happened oh no
oh no like a little toy flowers around
here hi lemon
let man what's up hey that's my bear
why'd you just throw your bear in there
did he unlock the door oh he did ok good
job bear come on oh oh is it a pull
that's a pull I'm an idiot ha bear whoa
you're freaky bear with you where are we
huh
all right so that is the Alpha of among
the sleep I hope you all enjoyed it and
it looks like it's got some great stuff
to offers I mean that there weren't that
many scares in the game but that's okay
be in this alpha but I'm sure they're
gonna be plenty when the monsters
finally start to show up it looks like a
really interesting diving into a kid
going into all these weird dimensional
rifts or something like that the whole
world around him is changing maybe it's
his imagination gone wild or maybe there
really is something really weird going
on or a combination of the bull so check
it out for yourself remember click the
link in the description please support
the Kickstarter they're pretty close to
their goal as far as I know or they're
on their way so support what you can if
you want this game to be released it's
gonna be awesome so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
ah
Oh
I